all right what do you got yeah different
breed all right this is sad uh this is
super sad on friday it was the first day
of astro fest which is
travis scott's festival just dedicated
to him then he has other artists pop up
on it's usually a two-day event on
friday the very first day a bunch of
people had actually bum rushed the vip
entrance so a bunch of people ended up
coming into the concert who didn't have
like tickets or anything but the victim
was 14 16 21 23 and 27 14.
i saw a video someone had their
five-year-old there
that's the thing it's a conjurer yeah
that's not worth a million years but
somebody is travis scott's known like he
promotes like he wants his audience to
get crazy as he said yeah because uh
this time last year there were three
people who were actually trampled during
his concert he had a different concert
where he actually told a guy who was on
the third story balcony to jump and try
to crowd surf he was paralyzed shortly
after that well they were they were
stomping on the the
this is also on live nation on also the
absolutely i saw a defense lawyer
talking about and they're like it's
really not on travis scott he promotes
like his issues he promotes it that's it
because he wants him to get crazy but
he's like he's more on the security and
live nation
you know with all the people there right
and then isaac who who works for us he's
been a travis scott concert he's like do
i be in the front row it's i would never
do it again because it's [ __ ] awful
jesus christ why because when he comes
on
he encourages everybody to get wild and
he encourages people to jump the
barricade and do all this crazy [ __ ]
he's like and people are just getting
smashed dude
there can be a worse way to die because
they say you just can't breathe no you
get a it's just a sea of people i'd
rather get shot in the face me too dude
just shoot me in the [ __ ] [ __ ] fat
i mean okay
and you can't bring your you can't bring
your hands down now you're like getting
you know i don't know what happened like
what goes on there because i go to a lot
of concerts especially like the hardcore
punk ones where like that's i mean
that's our world but like it's it's for
us it's just like a different etiquette
but is that 50 000 people
this is 50 yeah there actually has been
a large trend since then since this has
happened of different people performing
at arena stadiums basically different
artists saying like hey we're being told
that people are getting trampled people
are getting squished together everybody
we're stopping the show take one step i
guess travis said i guess travis said
that was like hey yo we need help down
here like this girl's past like he was
saying like we need help
this is what his problem is he like he
encourages like that craziness the
british the british soccer
federation went through this [ __ ] like
where people got one there was i came
around
oh dude and people got crushed they got
crushed against one side of a wall and
they they from that point on they did
all these measures you can't go to a
[ __ ] soccer game if you're part of a
if you're on a 50 000 holy [ __ ]
and there it is all of what is to be 50
000 people ran to the front oh my god
and you know because the mate obviously
trav scott's the headliner he brought
drake out so kids lost their [ __ ]
and rushed to the front oh my god
squeezed minutes before you don't even
know what the [ __ ] is happening dude
yeah it's really heartbreaking there's a
lot of videos circulating right now
about uh
people in the crowd where people are
screaming for help but then you can't
hear power he can't see though a lot of
people don't realize when those lights
are on oh there's you can't see that
yeah
yeah you can barely see the camera yeah
you're and you're you're like you're not
aware you're just there there you go
scott pauses afterward performance after
seeing the ambulance
yeah you got to stop
damn my girl said right one star his
first song i looked at my boyfriend said
we have to get out of here damn he said
i can't we can't i should remember
looking up and passing out jesus christ
there have been several ins uh several
different news articles that had came
out since this all happening that travis
scott had stopped his concert three
times to try to check what was happening
meanwhile there are a lot of people on
the hate train right now saying that
it's gonna happen but it's gonna should
but my thing like obviously he like
wants this craziness or whatever but at
some point like these people need to
take some responsibility the fans 100
who rush the thing like
you can as much security as you want in
the front
and what can they do if people are being
[ __ ] idiots and rush into the stage
and the person in front of you goes i
can't breathe and you keep [ __ ]
position well people get pushed behind
them too though that's the problem is
that you you don't even realize what the
[ __ ] is happening until it's too late
it's like a wave yeah that's exactly
what people described it as like
they would rush in and then like as
people are pushed pushing forward people
then like back up over time and that's
how people people are you know it's
crazy they know that that's why it's
really important you know what's crazy
is uh like all the haters online like
they need more security there and the
governor or the mayor houston came out
goes
uh astral world travis scott's contours
have more security than the world series
so stop that [ __ ] yeah like that okay
it's a question of how you barricade and
when you have no barriers and people can
just run to the front yeah it's gonna
happen i think that and then obviously
you can't do 50 000 people you can't
you're gonna have to limit the access
which make the price go through the roof
yeah or have seating where they can't
yeah they have some festivals have it
before they have it split yeah like if
you notice they don't see certain like
especially the festivals in europe
you'll see like
the crowd is like that's why there's
like why they don't use barricades like
if you watch like yeah for stuff like
that exactly why you create those
measures so people don't get we've had a
lot of this happen in the past i mean
yeah again in the soccer ball he's had
it happen before though
he he they're not to this bag
yeah no no
for him i think it's just like i'm i'm
here to get people crazy and have fun
obviously naturally but jesus which is
christ man
that's on the organizers and and how
they set up the infrastructure it's just
i would never go to travis.com i would i
love him and i love his collabs but i
would never go to a concert ever ever
but you're not 20. yeah yeah true you
know
and trampled i was always afraid jesus
christ i'm always so scared i'm always
in the outside i took the the logan paul
floyd mayweather if i was working i'm
looking around i see all of logan's team
and floyd's team i'm like why are they
so close to the ring and in my head i'm
thinking oh if something pops off this
is gonna be a nightmare like there's not
much security my security guard was 400
pounds and not fast so literally i think
during the second round they gave me
personal security i go i'm going to get
out of here you dude you get the best
scene in the house you i know i have
anxiety i'm gonna watch it from the back
so i went all the way to the back well
we were in philly we'd done a show and
like in philly and and in like certain
parts of this and boston people get
aggressive and when they're drinking and
i remember you and i were like i
remember you said hey these because
you're from denver and you were like
this [ __ ] philly crowds i was like
they're notorious for being aggressive
we got the [ __ ] boston
same thing we're like let's get the [ __ ]
out don't get down i don't want to be
near that i don't want to i don't need
to be in the middle of what the [ __ ] and
then
stab shoot or fight you know